Michigan State's Tom Izzo how are you
coach I'm doing fine
this crazy time is about to say crazy
time crazy even you probably were hoping
that there's basketball going on all day
so you have something to talk about no I
know but again we're talking about
bigger things you know and and that's
why I'm saying like so what are you
what's been the what was the
conversation with you and your players
about all this honestly you know I I
said I actually had an early morning
meeting on yesterday and then I uh I was
gonna practice and we had a great
practice I was surprised glad to tell
him that to be no fans in the stands and
all that this was yesterday morning
Michigan was supposed to play Rutgers
right at noon and at about 10:00 2:00 or
something they came in for a practice we
were going to be done at noon and we
were going to drive down the nd and they
told us that it's cancelled okay so I
tell the players that and then by 3:00
o'clock they talked about the NCAA being
cancelled and I didn't want them to find
out on Twitter or some so I called a
meeting at 4:30 and then 4:20 they
released it hmm and that was a
tear-jerking meeting for this you know
senior for caches who had come so far
from all he's been through this year it
was you know I didn't feel for the
seniors in all sports you know and yet
as you say you know it's it's bigger
than life I I was hoping that they'd
postpone it for a couple weeks till we
got our our arms around this things I
don't know if anybody does have their
arms around it right now and see what
happens but I guess it just wasn't able
to be that way so now we move on and you
know I think our both our schools I
think are all but closing down this week
right as far as everything so it's it's
unbelievable it is unbelievable and so
can you let me in on what your
conversation was with Cassius again as
you mentioned his journey this year just
told him that you know life's not always
fair but there's bigger things in life
than basketball and and I said somehow
some way you know he's got to use this
that you know we always say well there's
a next year and well there is the
tournament or well there's the Big Ten
tournament you know and I try to tell
all our players this is well you you
hear it all your life live each day like
it's your last well you don't I don't
live to die but I also hopefully it it
you know it teaches guys that you better
take advantage of every second you have
and and for cash as I said hopefully you
have a future still and now we got to
look towards that Tom Izzo here on the
Rich Eisen show was there a sense of
unease in preparing however for your
game while you were doing that I mean I
played at Northern Michigan so uh you
know I can I played in front of no fans
a lot of I tried to make light of that
right um that it's not all that bad but
I don't think uneasiness as far as
worrying about anything I was on a nice
nest wondering how you know I think they
felt bad that the only people to be
there was their immediate family no
girlfriends no aunts and uncles things
like that you get to that pinnacle of
your career or your season and you this
is when people get to celebrate the good
times and because you are deep into the
Big Ten or NCAA tournament you're
playing for something that's you know
really big and as far as what we do as
coaches are as players but then I think
you know the reality of making
everybody's healthy and all these things
take a bigger stand so I don't know if
it was uneasiness I think it was the
unknown and that's the whole thing with
this disease right you know it's the
unknown that's maybe scarier than the
known yeah I know so who do you who is
the team or the school reaching out to
in order to inform you of what the risks
were or what could go down I mean what
can you walk me through yeah I think
that's the hard part you know I I think
so many people got on Twitter and got on
or you know TV and everybody's talking
about which should be doing it all I
said
let's talk to our medical people you
know and and that all happened so fast
that we didn't get much into that it was
all canceled before you could really
step forward and much of that and now I
think that's what's happening all over
and that's why I mean everybody I mean
in the state of Michigan we're closing
elementary schools high schools I think
Michigan Michigan State I think all the
schools are going to be more or less
closed
you know things will be online it's a
bizarre time and yet it's I think
drastic situations take drastic measures
and I I do respect that people are
trying to do what's best for everybody I
just don't know what that is I know you
know do you even you go out to eat here
what do you do well did you get any
specifics on on them the I guess science
of it medical or how to handle it what
you passed on here kids just you know
nobody's shaking hands with anybody now
and right and yet you know if you're in
a room with somebody I mean if you know
my worry at a campus was okay we closed
the campus down or we you know say
classes are closed down is that mean
everybody heads to the bars you know you
might remember back in your college days
and and that's worrisome you know so it
was just with everything that I that I
was worried about and you know you say
that you know fever and coughing and
this and that you know a lot of like flu
symptoms but sometimes they say that
right now you know you could have it not
absent them so it is a scary time and
we're just trying to deal with it day by
day but I met with my players now and
some of them will be going home at least
for a week and and doing things online
tom izzo here on the Rich Eisen show are
you are you off the recruiting trail for
the time being as well we're not allowed
to go anywhere and even in recruits to
high schools you know they've canceled
all the high school tournaments so
there's
you know I I guess in their own way I'm
gonna have a week or two to like I've
never had since I've been in this job
now I'm I guess I'm supposed to stay
home - yeah
whatever happens you know in these jobs
you kind of work in a lot of hours and
right now I I guess on some way that's
what I got to look at I don't know how
that'll be I you know I hope my wife
puts up a couple days I'll tell you
there's a lot of people saying well as
you mentioned like what do we talk about
in the sports world - you know when that
happens I think there should be a show
face time with mooch is Owen mooch I
would paint and watch a face time
between the two of you guys because he
was coming to the Big Ten Tournament I
said on Thursday night it it didn't look
like I thought we were gonna play but it
didn't look like we're gonna have
anybody in the stands right and he says
but I'm related to you and I'm not
claiming you so few minutes left here at
Michigan State's Tom Izzo Geno Auriemma
I mentioned this with Jay Bilas last
hour he came up with an idea or he
forwarded an idea yesterday that these
are obviously unique times as you
pointed out you've never been home for
this amount of time that seniors should
be allowed to have an extra year of
eligibility next year that this should
not cost the end of a college career for
somebody just because this pandemic has
happened what do you think about that
idea you know I I heard you know III
actually I talked to my I I'm not
disagreeing with that you know the
problem is like football got to play
there a whole year or basketball got to
play you know 31 games and just didn't
get to play in the tournament but you
know you got to look at places like our
golfers or tennis players or you know
they don't even get this are baseball
players they don't even get to play in
their senior year season one day and I I
think there should be something done on
a special occasion because this is a
unique
I mean I've never heard of this it's
been on the years I've been alive and so
it is unique and I think there should be
unique measures because I I mean I look
at a thing like I think it was Shabazz
Napier they beat us in the Elite Eight
in like 14 or 13 or something like that
and he went on to have an unbelievable
tournament they were a seven seed they
won the national championship he became
a first-round pick I believe because of
it you know and people are gonna lose
opportunities both in high school in
college so I think there should be
something done I think Gino is maybe
right on what would be the again we can
go down this this path right now fully
aware knowing and I will say this on our
behalf as well your behalf that there
are larger issues clearly that's going
on in the world but what would be the
the issues nuts and bolts from somebody
from your position to make that happen
scholarship wise or or commitments to
playing time yeah I don't think they'd
have to give a few more scholarships I
don't think a ton I don't think many
people have foreseen years and if you do
maybe like in our case maybe Cassius
Winston tries to go to the NBA doesn't
come back you know whatever whatever but
I just think the opportunity for those
kids that may be you know what if you're
we're a tweener kid and had a chance
maybe you know you to get to the NBA or
to get the Major League Baseball er or
golf or tennis or whatever it is senior
years sometimes make a big difference
and so I just I think it would be a
couple scholarships and there'd be some
strange parts to it but if we're totally
looking at the student athlete like we
always say we are I think those guys
that have paid their dues deserve a
chance to finish in a way that they can
finish so so you're just gonna spend
next couple weeks at home that's
basically the plan just stand still I
mean we're not allowed out alright and
on at least until May and you know I
don't know
you know there's no way my wife's
putting up me through that long and so I
might I don't know take up fishing or
something go to a pond I don't know what
I'm gonna do
I'll be calling mooch I'll be calling
you any time do you copy
talking a lot of people and I'm sounds
like I'm making fun of it I'm sure no no
not at all and no it's serious this is
serious business I mean and I uh and I
want to make sure that we all stay
healthy you and your family me and mine
but I also I do feel for those kids and
I look at what Cassius went through this
year and and there's a lot of those so I
hope they can come up with something but
I not sure that that's gonna happen I'll
just I'll be one of those times in life
you're right and all the people that
were depending on the hourly wages to
work the Big Ten Tournament weren't the
NCAA tournament Tom I mean it is it is
just it is quite something for everybody
to try and figure this thing out but
we're all we're all smart enough I think
and we're all compassionate enough you
know we all just open our here we are
you know right and and and I agree with
you and that's the issue with this we
talked about the Michigan and Michigan
State people are gonna work together on
this one
that's right that that's right that just
to show you didn't even read that and I
I think that's an honorable thing you
said and this is where our country's got
to come together but you're talking a
lot of people you know we're going at
pro arena is working at baseball in this
and tournaments and cities that are
depending on those kind of things
there's gonna be a lot of repercussions
but the best part will be is if we get
everybody healthy and keep everybody
healthy and and we'll live to fight
another day
that's it Tom love you man thanks for
calling in we may just just get just
keep checking back in on you thinkin you
do that and I appreciate it and god
bless you guys out there and take care
of your family you got it right back at
you that's Tommy's right you got it
right back at you that's Tom Izzo
Michigan State's Tom Izzo right here in
the Rich Eisen show